c'est une maîtresse d'école à ses élèves
qu'est ce que vous aimeriez à avoir
tiens-toi benoît qu'est ce que tu
aimerais avoir dit me noue avec la
famille on est en appartement moi
j'aimerais bien avoir une maison j'ai
des potes qu'une maison ils ont un
jardin une table de ping pong hasard
bécue ouais ça doit être sympa
et toi qu'est ce que tu aimes en avoir
jamais moi j'aimerais bien avoir comme
jeu de potes qui ont une maison de
campagne
c'est génial on respire la merde toute
la semaine dans l'abolition
et puis le week-end ils partent et où
ils courent ils vont à la pêche y voit
la nature les oiseaux j'aimerais bien
avoir une maison de campagne
et toi marius justement avoir l'humour
est on a tous si nous on a tous la
maîtresse elle un peu intrigué c'est un
quartier populaire quand même aidé il
commence à vous avez tous nourrir du
jour ma grande soeur elle est rentrée à
la maison avec un noir mon père a dit
tiens il nous manque un peu de ça
à toi cette bataille est ce que tu as
déjà vu une tomate chanter donc moi j'ai
déjà vu une carotte râpée enfin voulez
mais ça les enfants vont les besoins
matt carottes quand vous offrait à
l'oignon fait moins 1,6 g d'une munition
vous vous appelle titre c'est pour la
banda du mmc pour la battle pas si sûr
une boulangerie sim et d'un des nazis
monsieur non on n'a pas de tarte pour
nom n'a pas dix ans bas demain il
s'agira donc voir ou non non je disais
unis hier on se bat à touba reviennent
ça et les copains est accusé d'avoir
fait non non à battre à tokyo on n'a pas
trop puisé quoi vais-je ils sont quand
même une quinzaine et toi à son mari
j'ai fait un tout bon comme bon il ya de
la demande pour faire 4 ball qui envoie
est tombé trentaine de tarte aux pommes
toute la nuit fille trop beau et trop
mignon manière inattendue
[Musique]
[Rires]
tout
[Applaudissements]
jeudi matin sur l'ognon tout à l'heure
vous inquiétez pas pour l'instant on est
encore dans les légumes propres d'accord
vous inquiétez pas maintenant c'est une
offre qui est en tête de cette deuxième
battle oui ou alors bon un arabe
donc ça milite algériens qui ont
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
avais tu es et tu laisses atteint je les
adore j'ai envie de le lasser le mot
alors cinq minutes algérien qui revient
de sa caserne parce qu'ils avaient envie
de sa femme dont il demande à son
commandant trois jours de congés son
commandant lui donne trois jours de
congés il arrive chez lui s'aperçoit que
sa femme est indisposé lui fait
comprendre qu'elle ne disposait donc il
est dégoûté de voir comment je vais
faire et tout c'est pas comment la faire
et il faut que je trouve une solution
est tout il va appeler son commandant
mais à toute sa famille sa belle famille
chez lui du coup il va parler à son
commandant avec des termes un peu
militaire et donc qu'il appelle son
commandant et dit oui commandant ici
oméga aux problèmes en bas attaque
alerte rouge prolongé le congé alerte
rouge en bas prolongé le congé et son
commandant et lui répond directement ai
dit oui ici oméga ont joui oméga ans je
vous entends oui oui oui attaqué par
derrière revenu immédiatement
[Applaudissements]
je crois que ça joue entre tito ferrasse
approche william frey à fotolia bataille
malian alors non jeanne moreau va vous
raconter une blague d'accord alors c'est
l'histoire d'un homme extraordinaire qui
a un jardin magnifique ce mois et se
promènent jardin du luxembourg et son
chien vraiment il sait tout faire c'est
un très beau chiffre est à chaque fois
que quelqu'un ne croise en effet lui dit
mais qu'est ce qu'il est pour votre
petit chien et s'appelle yukky yuppy
lyon qui sait tout faire
yuki lève la patte il est là nous qui
lève la patte gauche élèves la patrie ou
qui croissent et partie croisé à paris
ou qui tourne comme ça sont en l'air le
chien fait tout est à ce moment là rien
très beau jeune homme qui passe comme ça
et le maître dit donc lyon pied et
maintenant si ce monsieur guillon qui
suce le monsieur bon je te montrerai
c'est l'an dernier
[Applaudissements]
ce côté là je vous donne ma première
c'est que c'est quoi je suis dit tu es
le tenant du canada une hystérique qui
fait non mais si si ça les histoires
drôles à tous adhérents sont fourbes et
c1 coupe à la femme elle est dans le lit
comme ça à l'hôpital c'est son vieux
tous les deux elle a des perfs elle a
des machins masquer son mari villa lui
tient la main d'où un moment donné elle
pousse un peu le mince que c'est mon
amour mon amour
il fait oui qu'est-ce qu'il ya qu'est-ce
qu'il ya l'amour de ma vie qu'est-ce
qu'il fait écoute j'ai une dernière
chose à demander une dernière chose
avant de partir il fait tout ce que tu
veux mon amour tout ce que tu veux je
ferai tout ce que tu veux
il vit fais moi l'amour une dernière
fois avec ce que ça va pas enfin machine
est à l'hôpital tient des fils partout
des matins des trucs pas possibles
effets moi l'amour je t'en supplie mais
moi j'ai mauvaise dernière fois une
dernière fois et mécénat pop
il prend la porte mais niche est
cyclique bloque la porte et puis monte
sur le lit doucement avec beaucoup de
tendresse il commençait à faire l'amour
avec sa femme à ce moment-là et un rouge
qui monte aux joues elle est au mieux de
plus en plus heureuse c'est merveilleux
il faut la moss est sublime c'est
extraordinaire matin et ça se termine en
apothéose lna en pleine forme est là les
perfs en balance les intrus qui déchire
le vase
elle fait bien on se tire g en pleine
forme et lui reste sur le liant la mi
temps l'amf est question mon amour quand
je pense que j'ai bu sovema m
[Rires]
les nancéens m'a dit vas-y oise
c'est un enfant qui joue au train
électrique et donc ils commencent à
jouer train électrique et son kit rhin
effet choo choo choo gare de montpellier
garde [ __ ]
et il continue to guard du var que des
cônes à sa mère elle commence à leur
gare d'allan peu plus tôt il continue
vetcho chucho gare de lyon gares de cons
ça m'a vraiment plu sa vulgarité à
dimont vas-y tu prends contrats
électriques tu es puni le puits dans sa
chambre pendant trois heures
au bout d'un moment a dit bon on va
lever la punition elle va chercher libre
au caire en club la punition tu peux
retourner jouer le pied reprend sont
réels effets chucho choo gare de
montparnasse trois heures de retard à
cause d'une kaunas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors ces derniers
alors on est d'accord qu'on sait c'est
familial a ironisé mme a pu en quoi
faire les fous du à l'est d'alger tuant
une boucherie au passage il associe ce
matin six mois ceux-ci s'invente allons
loin de payer la saucisse tu te baise tu
fais ça m'a un peu de magie à saucisse à
[ __ ] dehors on part sans payer vu
amputer rené tient génie merci les gars
aussi sûrement le matin j'ai déjà fais
tu vas voir il va même pas 6 de passer
histoire pas que mourinho est un très
bon il faut payer un tir puissant à ce
système de santé de vos marques qui se
massent aux anciennes trois bars 4 mardi
marc ou des corniches un peu plus c'est
bon quoi donner à ceux ci sont en
échange la saucisse
ça fait au moins de ces marques j'ai
perdu
[Applaudissements]
avec m'hamed et ali vous savez que je
suis né en tunisie
oui ce que j'ai beaucoup beaucoup d'amis
d'enfance moi je suis un juif arabe et
puis moi j'ai des copains qui sont des
arabes musulmans et est donc si mohamed
ali et mohamed il arrive et fait le tri
lui fais avec mon sauveur ce matin il
fait roule très bien
je vis très bien mais j'étais à la
chasse je suis parti avec mon physique à
aa
j'étais là bringuebalant 5 à 20 petit
âne je marchais marché de la compagnie
fait vous d'accord avec ce que tu vas
dire encore comme bêtise effet tout d'un
coup wise as tu sais ce que je vois où
un lion ben tu vois les ans
vim tu vois un lion qui croient le lion
il te vois aussi oui les liens elle me
voit mai mois où elle avec mes petites
papattes j'y mets à courir faits et
alors
les lions c'est là les papattes il court
derrière toi wallace et aux effets oui
mais moi ou l'échevin marbre il fait les
lions et l'adieu espèce de bim
thumerelle que tu écris de frapper de
montrer qu'on est là désir la ville
armes aussi oui mais moi je grimpe en
europe
ils y ont hélas des griffes du principe
des ferments dans la vie tu attrapes il
bouffe
oui mais moi j'allais au bout de la
broche il est allé au bout de
si notre bouffe et annick et c'est comme
ça il fait oui mais moi je suis tombé de
la vie creusé un trou et je me suis
cachée sur la terre oui mais les murs il
t'a vu le sort de la petite bouffe
l'at-il fait un des meilleurs tubes
occupe rayon court
[Applaudissements]